ou du cosmos au cinéma fantastique il
n'y a qu'un pas qui nous conduit à
avoriaz au festival d'avoriaz ce
festival qui doit ce soir proclamé son
palmarès sept avoriaz ce qu'ont déjà
explosé duel mad max
elephant man avant de faire des ravages
dans les salles la nouveauté cette année
c'est enfin la participation de films
français qui exploite donc ce filon de
la science fiction et du fantastique qui
assure à quelques grands films en tout
cas les plus fortes recette jamais
enregistrée dans le monde entier le
fantastique va peut être détrôné le
comme le comique troupier qui était
jusqu'ici la poule aux oeufs d'or de nos
producteurs français palmarès donc ce
soit pour cette cuvée 83 et un prix
spécial antennes de l'antenne d'or yauba
grégoire nous donne déjà un avant goût
des horreurs qu'elle a pu voir
fini les mythes en carton-pâte jean
frankenstein dracula
l'équipe du muppet show vient d'imaginer
de fabriquer ces bêtes surnaturel qui
amène un nouveau genre dans le
fantastique le festival d'avoriaz 111
ans d'existence apporter chaque année sa
révélation avec mad max duel ou elephant
man il reste le baromètre dans la
production mondiale du fantastique où
les modes évoluent les poux vente
maintenant ce sont les problèmes
d'actualité guerre biologique mal de
vivre dans un monde robotisés ou les
objets se retourne contre vous
le frisson de peur seul appelé pour
preuve l'engouement de plus en plus
grand du public pour le fantastique
grâce haïti qui vient en tête des succès
de l'année
c'est sans doute pour cette raison que
les cinéastes français ont décidé de s'y
mettre pour un film en compétition
avoriaz on n'avait jamais vu cela
je te dire que moi je suis ravi parce
que au moins ça lève le voile sur un
point qui m'a toujours fait sauter en
l'air à savoir que les gens vous disais
on fait pas de cinéma fantastique en
france parce qu'on n'a pas les moyens on
n'est pas aussi
argent 2 que les américains bien sûr on
a autant de talent que c'est bien connu
on n'a pas de pétrole mais on a des
idées
et moi j'ai toujours pensé qu'on avait
ni pétrole ni l'idée en tout cas dans ce
domaine et que ce qu'il faut pour faire
du cinéma fantastique c'est précisément
un scénario de dassier et des choses qui
rebondissent le démon dans l'île c'est
l'histoire d'un médecin anny duperey qui
accepte un poste dans une île pour
oublier un drame personnel
très vite la jeune femme va être le
témoin d'événements inhabituels des
objets quotidiens provoquent des
accidents des morts étranges où est
impliqué jean claude brialy incarnation
du mal
en france on a tendance à vous mettre
des étiquettes cuisse et à la comédie
lui la tragédie bon on peut pas tout
jouer et bien évident que moi si j'étais
torse nu dans une mine ses frères tout
le monde mais je pense que de jouer un
jeu plus intérieure plus fort
j'occupe une noire avec des avec des
sentiments et en regard plus dur c'est
passionnant pour un acteur dont on dit
qu'il est gentil dont on croit qu'il a
du charme
ce qu'il ya d'intéressant à faire dans
dans ce genre de film qui va tous mais
poursuivent-ils en particulier c'est
comment construire un personnage quand
il n'y a pas de support psychologique
évident pas d'histoires sentimentales
évidente non plus et qu'en fait c'est
l'histoire le suspense et l'action qui
sont les moteurs du scénario
alors haïti français sur la place de la
concorde où avoriaz pourquoi pas